and just you know put it in powers and
go one on one and he gets all the way to
the basket
but there's the defense by cappello he
comes over and he's
looking around but this is just a very
poor shot here by memory
how do you not give the ball to kyle
lowry he's standing there wide
open
atlanta ball
kevin hurdry the trigger man bounce into
trey
five seconds trey driving trey
looking gets rid of it tony still for
the win
good he beats the buzzer and the hawks
have the victory
[Applause]
121-120
it looked like a busted play but all of
a sudden
tony stell ends up with the basketball
and he gets
mobbed by his teammates wins it at the
buzzer with a three-pointer how about
that
well toronto had no one to blame but
themselves the hawks just kept fighting
[Applause]
tony snell with the game winner
and just his second field goal of the
game
trey found him open over the uncharging
stanley johnson and the hawks
come storming back to win the ball game
what a finish
the hottest guy in the nba outside the
ark these days
and he trained
man hey you know get take your hats off
to the atlanta hawks
they just kept fighting kept coming and
they're gonna get out of here with a win
and a big win indeed
tony stella is the hero and he's
standing by with kelly
wow tony what a finish take us inside
that final huddle
and then how the play unfolded there in
the last seven seconds what you're
thinking
tony i think coach mcmillan was asked
today
about this stretch that you're on and he
said in practice
you're just knocking them down one after
the other and you can only hope you
carry it over to the floor and you've
been able to do exactly
that even in big moments how have you
done it
a 24-8 run there to pull this victory
off
what changed in the final six minutes of
this game tony
and that's exactly what you guys did
will you discuss with me for just a
moment
what you and clint capela have been able
to do
inside and specifically his job on the
boards tonight
and last thing tony when's the last time
you've been mobbed by your teammates
like that
and just describe how big this win was
to kind of set the tone for the second
half
well we certainly hope you get to
celebrate a little bit more in the
locker room thanks for joining us here
tonight congrats on the win
kelly and tony thank you tony snell
amazing he has hit 33
of his last 51 three-point
shots and none bigger than that one
right there to win it
what a shot and as confident
a stroke as you'll see as he told kelly
just find a lane for trey to find you
runs to the spot nothing but net
we'll be back saturday as the hawks
return to atlanta to take on the kings
our coverage begins at 7 eastern time on
saturday
but lots to recap the happy totals
and more from jerome and stinger on
hawk's live post game it's all coming up
on fox sports southeast tony snell
the game winner at the buzzer